please use your Liberty to promote ours
that powerful plea was written in a 1997
New York Times op-ed by Myanmar's now de
facto civilian leader Aung San su cheap
she's one of the most influential
leaders in the world and today one of
the most controversial she's won a Nobel
Peace Prize and spent years under house
arrest as a political prisoner but
despite being the Democratic icon that
she's been for decades many believe
suits she has failed to uphold her own
principles when it comes to others like
me and Mars Muslim minority there were
Hingis hey guys I'm Sonia
welcome to aj+ and this Sunday I want to
talk about on sunsoo Chi's powerful rise
as a symbol of democratic struggle and
the controversy that now threatens to
undermine everything she's been
celebrated for so uncensored she's story
begins with her dad
Major General Aung Sun he's the icon of
independence in Myanmar having fought
against the British he laid the
foundation for the union of Burma which
is what Myanmar was called before 1989
young son didn't live long enough to see
his dreams of a free and democratic
Burma he was assassinated in 1947 right
before the country was granted
independence from the British at age 15
young son su Qi left Burma with her
brothers and mother for India at that
time her mother was appointed as the
ambassador to the country uncensored she
would go on to spend most of the
following years outside Myanmar
eventually moving to the UK which became
her home now while there was all this
movement in her life Myanmar had gone
through some major political upheavals
from a democratic country to coming
under who to rule in 1962 the coup was
led by General maewyn and resulted in an
isolated corruption filled country where
political dissent was crushed but it
wasn't until 25 years later when su Chi
returned to care for her sick mother
that she decided to take a stand against
what was happening in the country 1988
was a big turning point for Myanmar
massive protests against the future
started forming in the streets and su
Chi was moved by what she was seeing she
started making political speeches and
the people were listening and by the way
when I say massive protests I'm talking
about half a million students and
civilians and that kind of people power
freaked out the military government who
responded with violence
despite the crackdown on Sen su Chi with
her charismatic speeches her father's
name became the voice of the opposition
and the government noticed her influence
and placed her under house arrest at the
same time in an effort to prevent
further protests they also agreed to
hold an election in a few years this was
when the military decided to change the
country's name from Burma to Myanmar it
was a way of saying hey we're here and
we're not going anywhere
now the military government did hold a
vote in 1990 expecting to be reconfirmed
as the country's legitimate leaders
instead guess what happened
unghh son su Chi and her party the
National League for Democracy won that
vote should have returned Myanmar to a
democracy but the military government
ordered sushi to stay under house arrest
and spent the next several years trying
to curb her political power we will have
to create opportunities to do more as a
political party to operate as a
political party the generals even
enacted a constitutional amendment that
banned her from becoming president
instead of sinking into irrelevance on
sunsuit she actually became more
influential during her house arrest
since she believed in the non-violent
activism of Mahatma Gandhi and Martin
Luther King jr. she found power in
following the government's house arrest
orders she stayed behind her fence but
would hoist herself up to give speeches
to the crowds that would gather in her
yard it was this sort of resolve that
earned her the admiration of both the
people of Myanmar and the international
community which awarded her the Nobel
Peace Prize in 1991 unsung su chi went
on like this for over 20 years and then
myanmar reached a boiling point
massive protests once again broke out in
the streets and this time it was
thousands of saffron robed monks who led
the uprising the world couldn't ignore
news of the military government beating
protesting monks and then the killing of
a Japanese photojournalist Kenji negai
who was shot dead while covering the
demonstrations there were global
protests calling for peace in Myanmar
and for unk song su Chi to be freed this
increased international pressure on
military generals to give up control led
to a series of moderate reforms
including releasing su Chi from house
arrest in 2010 the hooter also held a
new round of elections and since
uncensored she was a free woman
she was poised to finally take her place
as leader of the country but the
military refused to lift a
constitutional ban on her be
president that amendment by the way
states that anyone with foreign-born
children can hold the office so she
couldn't become president but she still
became the civilian leader of the
country when her party won in 2015 she
instead was given the position of state
councilor which has given her the power
and influence to lead the country this
moment was seen as monumental that maybe
this was it this was Myanmar's
transition back into a democratic
country but there's one issue that's
overshadowed sushis fight for freedom
and her legacy the Roe hinga though her
hinga are a Muslim minority ethnic group
living in Myanmar in the western state
over kind
now the rahaga are forced to live in
some pretty abysmal conditions they are
not considered citizens they have very
few rights and they face violence from
the military and from civilians
including organized mobs of monks human
rights groups have shown that the
systematic violence towards the Raheja
has been tantamount to ethnic cleansing
even genocide and while the violence
against and the displacement of the
rahaga started well before su Chi came
into power there was this belief among
many that now that she was free she'd be
able to advocate for the rights of the
ro hinga but she didn't and she hasn't
instead in a 2017 interview with the BBC
she denied ethnic cleansing of there
were hangers I don't think there's as
mackensen going on I think ethnic
cleansing is too strong an expression to
use for what's happening but many in the
international community family disagree
I heard allegation after allegation of
horrific events like these slitting of
throats
indiscriminate shootings setting alight
houses with people tied up inside and
throwing very young children into the
fire as well as gang rapes and others
sexual violence
she's also denied entry to UN teams into
the trouble of a kind' state teams who
want to investigate the conditions of
the rahaga critics have also pointed to
additional shortcomings including
ongoing military conflicts in other
regions the jailing of critics and a
general lack of transparency within her
government and in an interview with Al
Jazeera sources who worked with her have
said that she doesn't listen doesn't
like to be questioned and runs her party
like a dictator and though she is trying
to lead a country that's been under a
military dictatorship for decades so far
her story hasn't exactly turned out
thought it would and maybe the better
question to ask is if um son su Chi will
use her Liberty to promote the liberty
of others so the story of UNK sunsuit
she unfolded in a really unexpected way
what do you guys think did you guys know
about Jung sang-soo Chi and what do you
think about her now let us know in the
comments and also let us know other
people that you want us to profile
whether they're leaders of movements of
parties of countries and don't forget to
Like share and subscribe and tune in
next Sunday when we come at you with
another great video